Britain's National broadcaster the BBC
has faced questions from the government
over allegations involving one of its
leading presenters the Sun newspapers
reported that the male presenter paid 45
000 to a youth for sexually explicit
photos the young person was 17 when the
payments began the identities of the
presenter and the youth have not been
revealed let's go to our correspondent
Harry Fawcett in London sounding just
outside BBC headquarters so Harry how
did this all come about
well it came out through an article in
the Sun newspaper where the the mother
of the young person involved went to the
paper as you're saying none of the
people involved in this are being named
but she says that uh when her child was
17 years old they were contacted by this
unnamed well-known figure within the BBC
allegedly and was solicited for uh
sexually explicit images for which this
person is alleged to have paid
considerable amounts of money as you say
up to 45
000 US dollars in the three years since
that first Contact at one stage the
mother says there was a lump payment of
six and a half thousand US Dollars and
she also says that she went to the BBC
uh with this information nearly two
months ago and is complaining in the
newspaper that nothing apparently
appeared to have been done certainly the
person involved was not she says taken
off air as a result of this allegation
the BBC says that it is investigating
that it takes these sorts of allegations
extremely seriously and it also says
that such investigations also include
actively attempting to speak to those
who have contacted us in order to seek
further detail if we get no reply to our
attempts or receive no further contact
that can limit our ability to progress
things although saying that their
investigations were continuing I think
some people have interpreted that as a
as trying to put some of the blame onto
the people involved that the mother
involved that is attracted yet further
criticism and now the culture secretary
for the UK government has spoken to the
director general of the BBC on Sunday
seeking a very quick investigation she
says she received assurances that this
would be investigated swiftly and
sensitively
however you look at it this is not
coming down well on the BBC is it
no I think a lot of the resultant uh
reputational damage will to some extent
depend on exactly how this investigation
does proceed it will depend to some
extent on just how well known just how
senior a personality this allegation
relates to but also a lot of it will be
how the BBC is seen to respond so far
there has been considerable criticism
from both government ministers the
opposition as well the uh the Main
Finance spokesperson for the opposition
saying that the person involved should
have been taken off air immediately
while this investigation was underway
and so the BBC will have to protect the
any potential harm to this young person
who whose mother says has spiraled into
crack cocaine addiction as part of the
uh The Fallout from all of this we'll
also have to protect its own reputation
in terms of a swift investigation and it
has a duty of care to its other leading
male presenters some of whom have
publicly taken to social media to say
that it isn't them because a lot of
people are being named on social media
so there's a duty of care to those staff
members as well and of course there have
been other recent scandals involved in
the BBC uh most recently the chairman
having to resign over his involvement in
a loan deal arranged for the former
prime minister Boris Johnson
thank you for that Harry Fawcett there
for us in London